[Music]
New York is the greatest city in the
world
my city I was a kid in these streets and
I made it to the top I made my bombs
doing a piece of work for Don Carlo
Gambino like that I became a made man
dad I'm thinking maybe take a year off
do you know what you're doing to this
family
I will build something that nobody can
destroy so WellCare Salah was a fish in
the desert I never respected well you
killed the boss of us you will bring
down Hellfire there is no choice you
will need the support of all five
boroughs Queens Brooklyn Manhattan
Staten Island the Browns our job now is
to maintain leadership I nominate John
Gotti let everybody off now everybody
comes to this I'm sure proud of you you
should be running your own crew now mr.
Gotti are you the head of the Gambino
crime family the head of my family mrs.
Bobby do you know your husband Esther
living beautiful Cod John's getting too
much press that can't go unchecked it
was meant for you you'll never believe
this kind of scrutiny before what are
you saying on the tapes I said a lot of
things that could get a lot of people in
trouble dad said wear it I'll go for a
cliff feed you then you would not bring
him into that well this life of ours is
a wonderful life if you can get away
with it
Johnson has been an informant for the
FBI you fight - you can't fight no more
[Music]
never back off ever
we walked together and we fought
together this is the life
[Music]
you